welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of rick and
morty season five episode five
a morning canon gridi titled of course
after american graffiti george lucas's
pre-star wars film about
joyriding teens in the 60s kind of like
morty and summer and bruce jetbag do
with rick's homicidal car
from hellraiser to transformers to
galactus to all the crap in that karaoke
bar
i am gonna break down all the hidden
jokes and references and horny animation
details that you might have missed so
outside the smith home is their other
red car that we've seen in past episodes
it's now being used after their griswold
station wagon crashed and was covered in
that sperm monster goo last episode and
as always the crack around the house's
perimeter is visible reminding us of
when the house was teleported in season
one's rick c business
which beth actually recalls this episode
i am giving you two trust and respect so
if you mess up and teleport this house
it'd be wise to stay on it and not come
back
rick takes a box of occult items off his
top shelf
this box has sat right above the time
travel stuff box in every garage scene
since the pilot and now we finally know
what's in it contents include this
one-eyed pyramid head with a pentagram
but on the back of it as a number two
making me wonder if this could be
another gravity falls easter egg since
we know justin roiland and alex hirsch
love referencing each other's shows
in this case maybe those three numbered
journals or to bill cipher though
doesn't have a top hat so it's probably
not bill but you can see there is at
least one more of these things
in the box so maybe if rick aligns the
three of them they do something there's
also a three eyed skulls
in this case the spiritual third eye
being a literal third
eye hole a severed arm with a finger
missing maybe a neutralized monkey paw
and then this chalice made out of some
creature's foot
beth says someone played barry white
over the racetrack speakers and now
there's a seven horse pregnancy yeah
there tend to be 14 horses on a
racetrack in a single race
so seven could be if all those horses
coupled off or maybe one super fast
stallion that got to
seven mares by an o's beth later
delivers these horses pretty quickly
i thought you were birthing horses yeah
they're horses it takes like two minutes
yeah because horses are fast and it's a
callback to rick's chud baby which was
born and burrowed within seconds
beth leaves summer in charge no parties
and no vape
stuff i remember summer tried to vape
brake fluid and children of mort last
season
and in pickle rick they had to go to
therapy partly because summer got caught
huffing pottery glaze
summer and morty argue about bruce shut
back it's only a matter of time before
bruce learns you're a creepy little
grandpa's boy always climbing up into
alien assets
or the summersmith shampoos her pubes
rumor okay
you came to play in fairness we don't
really know if she actually does this
all we know is that it's a rumor that
she can't live down but she probably
does we all got weird skeletons in our
crotches
summer responds to morty's line about
family
you're so good you have to like it or
you're sexist so i'm gonna break down a
fart here forgive me but we later
learned that rick can smell adventure on
his car
rick and smell avengers
sorry i farted
now at first i thought maybe to rick
adventure just smells like jerry's farts
but he may have been smelling summer's
nervous farts from their terrifying
adventure but then jerry farting helped
throw rick
off the scent rick and jerry arrived
through a portal
rick's first use of a portal gun this
season showing that he must have gotten
a new one since he's lost his old one to
that cyberpunk bird in the season
premiere
jerry assembles a hell cube to summon
demons inspired by the hellraiser
cinebites hellraiser inspired by clive
barker's novella the hellbound heart in
both cases summoned by
a puzzle box called the lament
configuration i love their character
design with one wearing a collar of
blood syringes another with a tv screen
wedged into his head with the color bars
as he's yellow and red it looks like rca
connectors into the nipples
jerry invites them all in you'll love
this i call it jeri-oki
i'll let you guess what yeah they glow
purple as they take pleasure in this but
notice they only do this after rick
cringes because it's his suffering that
triggers them now the bar is named
phantasma which
is spanish for ghost so all this is rick
being stuck in a dinner for schmuck's
scenario because he sold the set of
bites faulty skin hooks which actually
he later uses to escape because they
never replaced them
jerry says hey we're in luck gang
they've got the entire smash mouth
catalog
though we criminally never get to hear
him sing walking on the sun or shrek's
anthem's
all-star or i'm a believer come on morty
opens the door too
newest kid in school just transferred in
hasn't done anything embarrassing yet
yeah bruce shutback is voiced by darren
chris
but that was dan harmon doing the theme
music teasing
hasn't done anything embarrassing yet
setting up bruce's coming humiliation
and post-credit scene
just for wearing the same pair of pants
two days in a row high school was the
worst
i love how bruce is not at all
impressive he actually looks like a
younger jerry
green polo similar hair just longer
plays classic snake just like jerry
loves simple
stupid games hey now that we're in this
hot summer weather it means a lot of
guys want to keep that facial hair down
and their face feeling
summery smooth or in some of our cases
like the lines between our beard and
neck feeling smooth
well thanks to our sponsor harry's you
can feel smoother than ever
harry's is a personal care brand that
delivers a close comfortable shave at a
fair price
as low as two dollars per refill they
support
great causes as they give one percent of
their global sales to nonprofit
organizations
that provide mental health care for men
veterans and lgbtq plus youth and
harry's is helping you
shave in a hassle-free way their german
manufactured blades are
sharper than ever and they're still the
same low price of only two dollars each
they have this high quality
weighted handle with a textured rubber
grip and a five blade razor cartridge
that just feels really great in your
hand and does an amazing job package
also comes with this great
shave gel it's really good for sensitive
skin for sensitive hearts mmm smells so
good
so redeem your trial set for just three
dollars when you go to harrys.com
new rockstars you'll get a five blade
razor weighted handle
a travel cover and their foaming shave
gel it's an incredibly great deal but
act
fast while supplies last now
interdimensional cable shows a
commercial for the story train from last
season's never ricky morty episode
another reminder that most of that
episode was in the non-canon
imaginations of morty and rick kind of
like the lego movie
actually if you put in that url it takes
you to the adult swim rick and morty
page
and more great interdimensional cable
content and now back to olympic diving
with bad swimmers
there he goes perfect dive
[Applause]
oh terrible swimmer yeah that guy comes
over with the hook ready to pull him out
summer offers some sofa wine want some
sofa wine
it's been stashed four weeks should be
good tasting
tight remember in the total recall
episode there was that dark memory that
summer recalled to verify beth's
existence
from the time when beth was super drunk
on wine mom are you driving me to
um yeah yeah yes what time oh my god are
you drunk
nobody my wife coach you're what oh god
oh my god are you okay i didn't i'm
gonna have a bruise
yeah so summer might have hidden this
wine from her mom that's why it's in the
sofa
morty stutters to bruce feel feel feel
feel free to have some grapes yeah he
actually accidentally says
feel fear at first which bruce really
should feel for the adventure ahead and
for his upcoming social humiliation
rick's security system is obviously
inspired by dennis nedry from jurassic
park
i said don't touch my also i just
watched jurassic park on cable
so good seriously though touch my
and i'll freeze your dick
and summer comes outside with the keys
keys so
uh let's do this yeah summer catches
herself and it slows down or walk to
look less thirsty
rick's car snaps at them you are not
rick yeah kari walgren who also voices
jessica on the show returns after
voicing this car in season two's the rix
must be crazy
ship keep summer safe keep summer
safe her weaponry later is actually
everything that we saw her packing in
that episode
morty is able to unlock her with the
logic problem and a joyride set to
yellows
yeah famous from ferris bueller's day
off when they joyride in cameron's dad's
ferrari which actually later gets joy
ridden by the other dudes
set to the star wars theme so in a
roundabout way we connect it back to
george lucas
behind jerry in the bar is this poster
with the charity brothers
chair and itty from the animated short
that justin royland and zach hadel
produced for seth rogen's hilarity for
charity special on netflix
also in the bar is a hell racers video
game another nod to hellraiser to the
left of that is a sign for foamies
that's the beer rick drank in the
planeteen episode and above the doorway
is a sign that reads tonight karaoke
tomorrow the world now also on the wall
is a sign reading karaoke because
people weren't loud enough the beer menu
lists alphabet ipa
bc swiller low life a take on miller
highlife
kellner's dark and light which is
actually a nod to rick and morty writers
pa
michael kellner and later there's a sign
that reeve kellner's it tastes like
ass writers pas work their asses off on
shows give this guy a break i'm sure
it's an inside joke the list also has
special railgun shots yeast
dark there's another poster that calls
it yeast the beer that
raises you up ying sting a take on
yingling
ipape and i am in grape pain which is a
callback to bird person revealing bubble
of a dub dub translates to i am in great
pain and then high iq
a nod to that meme that you need a high
iq to appreciate rick and morty very
much true and then on the other side on
the special sport at the bottom it reads
has anyone seen my chalk
another sign reads hog and appetizer not
the stage there's a pennant for
squanchy and then a patron wears a shirt
with planetina's logo
now meanwhile in the bee plot on the
joyride they terrorize some male boxians
one of the buildings is a usps dropbox
with a forever stamp flag
they pass through a black hole their
bodies liquefy into it and they freak
out this one dude piloting what looks
like a star wars pod racer which
actually george lucas put into phantom
menace as a throwback to his own street
races in american graffiti though here
are the engines in that guy's chin
yeah those are totally balls the car
stops the fun shorts showing them images
of things she's been recording including
apparently morty peeing out the window
on another bean
all of them have to wear space helmets
just so they can roll down the window so
instead the car takes over
first off going fishing using the lure
of a freaking solar system
in planets being pulled in its gravity
wake actually similar to how dr who used
tardis to tow earth though based on the
scale of the ship this must be a tiny
solar system
kind of like the planet dwarf terrace
nine in the season two finale which had
a circumference of only 330 yards she
ends up catching a galactus like being
galactus devourer of worlds from the
marvel comics but she says rick never
lets her do this meaning rick must have
refused to hunt galactuses the car is
going rogue here maybe breaking a kind
of treaty they park at owl's diner which
is similar to how in american graffiti
they go to arnold's diner which is
actually the same location seen in ron
howard's other title happy days there's
a rolling robot waitress kind of like
rosie from the jetsons and rick's car
gets in a fight with a
change former but instead of the
transformer autobot symbol it's a hang
ten hand
actually this particular one looks a lot
like the green mitsubishi eclipse that
paul walker drove in the first the fast
and the furious film meanwhile his
friend has a head piece that looks kind
of like rick's hair
the car wants to lose her virginity you
have virginity i don't know
don't all objects isn't a doorknob a
virgin
not mine never doorknob morty did
technically lose his virginity to an
inanimate object well it's kind of
animate the gazorbazorp droid in the bar
bathroom there's more graffiti
reading high iq you gotta have one
another nod to the very true meme the
flesh curtains really suck the flesh
curtains is actually the name of rick's
squanchy and bird person's band then for
a good time call 8675309 and onto the
tommy two-tone song beryllium zeppelin
for
led zeppelin but like lead they
intentionally misspell beryllium and
then
in the stall there's hail satin i like
fleece no more power ballads probably
because
they hate hearing them all the time on
karaoke night and mutang
obviously for wu-tang clan but with a
symbol of the greek letter mew
and then on the paper towel dispenser a
sticker kalax queen maybe four kalaxian
crystals
rick strug from that rixie business
episode which also gets listed among
their contraband later
possession of kalaxian crystal dust
space tahoe seems modeled on the bro
early 90s ski school movies the change
former realizes rick's car
is a just car it vomits oil and screws
all over her and then she burns them
alive and actually during their brutal
escape along with the cinnabites
slaughtering the patrons you hear this
demonic music plane
and rick tells beth god damn it beth you
never follow hell demons to a second
location
it's always held a reference to my
favorite line from 30 rock
never go with a hippie to a second
location which by the way came right
after guest star carrie fisher said
help me liz lemon you're my only hope
again it all comes back to george lucas
so we go into hell
looming over the background are these
epic giant long-legged skeletons that
looks a lot like the salvador dali's
surrealist work the elephants but behind
them
craziest easter egg in the episode this
headstone of emmett brown
died 1885 from back to the future part
3.
no idea why this grave is in hell though
rick and morty was based on justin
roiland's channel 101 short doc and
marty
super gross and that doc probably
deserved to burn in hell
beth wear these kinky cuffs and jammed
dartboard darts into her face kinda like
pinhead
though the demon they face has ink pins
tugging his skin making him a different
kind of pen head
rick wears a leather daddy outfit which
is a more extreme version of his get up
in the scary terry episode with a marlin
pierced through his body even when that
marlin is removed the hole is still
there
the coatrack guy bouncer has clothespins
on his nipples and he carries his
clipboard made out of someone's head
with this braided ponytail
maybe it's a type of haircut that makes
him cringe and therefore
feels pleasure after escaping due to his
own faulty hooks and fleeing with beth
and jerry rick has had enough of this
adam's family referring to how
the addams family enjoys things that
should be painful or horrifying to most
people meanwhile the kids are
apprehended by an ape creature from the
zqpd
maybe for the zoological quadrant police
department their lawyer is allison
hannigan
no relation to the actor actually being
controlled via a chip jammed into her
head hey kind of like taskmaster
she calls bruce a sociopath military
brat who wanders the earth
changing people who don't need to be
changed which kind of sounds like wes
bentley's character in american beauty
and the chip blows up her head and a
hole in the wall allowing their escape
notice the car's lasers are red yellow
blue and green
a similar multicolored combo as voltron
which we know rick is obsessed with and
will be coming up later this season
meanwhile rick's pleasure pain converter
uses this demon with a hilarious stupid
grin plastered on his face and rick uses
this to kill all the other demons with
sincerity and much like in ferris
bueller's day off the kids have to rush
to beat their parents home
the living room on the tv is an ad for
hellamac industries hot sauce that
burns a hole through the table jerry
abruptly turns it off probably had
enough of hell for one day and then a
baby skull falls out of beth's hair
it's a baby skull that's worse it's
still a school night
yeah it's not a school night at the
beginning of the episode rick and jerry
said it was a friday night but the joke
here is that beth is just fumbling her
way out of this conversation and in the
post-credits scene bruce shut back
becomes bruce
pants actually recurring characters brad
and trisha return here and then he gets
jumped by a vengeful gang of male
boxians that's everything i found this
episode you can support new rock stars
by checking out our merch options at
newarkstarsmerch.com i think we've still
got a few left of these loki added time
shirts but they're going to be going
back in the vault soon
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow and subscribe to new
rockstars thanks for watching see you
next week bye
[Music]
you